okay so the next 365 days movie is now
here and if you thought the last two
years were bad in real life then you
haven't seen the last two 365 days this
tops off what's the worst trilogy of all
time but since we covered the last two
then you know we had to ride it out
until the end and finish up even though
we're almost out of ammo what q there
what even needs explaining comments but
grab me a cigarette because we're lubing
up and going in deep feel like i've been
kidnapped myself and forced to go
through this but smash the thumbs up
button like it's laura's box if you
enjoy the video and make sure you hit
subscribe to stick around through the
good and bad like your boy nacho without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into the next 365 days
[Music]
now i'm not a conspiracy theory but it's
where these movies started showing up
when the world turned to crap the finale
is going down worse in an ezra miller
apology for playing grand theft auto
hawaii and like all bad things it must
come to an end the last movie featured
the marriage of laura and massimo with a
ladder demanding that she no longer be
treated like an object the bloody cheek
of it massimo was of course taken aback
by this because who wouldn't be and when
nacho entered her life along with
massimo's twin brother adriano it all
went so nacho that's not your girl and
adriano you need to take adriano for an
answer
now adriano hobbed a deep resentment for
massimo due to him being born a couple
minutes before him finally though he
gets to go first and we discover early
on in this movie that he was killed due
to the events of the last one in the end
laura was shot too whilst she ran to
massimo showing nacho who she really
loved the third movie opens in the
aftermath of this with adriano six
inches deep sorry six feet deep now i
loved how they teased that it was laura
who was dead by having olga be like i
miss her so much and yeah love you you
only see her five minutes ago now from
the off you know that this script is
gonna be as melodramatic as it can be
and this fifty shades of shakespeare
follows nacho driving a wedge between
massimo and laura massimo is often
driving something into laura though and
hey my wife if you're watching this
video i swear those noises coming from a
room that they were they were for a
video they were for a video
now due to the death of adriano the
tensions between the families are worse
than me and my wife's are now and it all
spills over into the main plot the story
is basically a mix between music videos
and nightclubs and the worst softcore
pawn that you've ever seen it makes the
acting from jenny sins look like it's
daniel day lubis but if you're up to the
point that you're watching the third
movie you'll likely love it as much as
the director loves slow-mo at times i
was often just shazaming the songs and
if we're going off how much you added to
my spotify library then it's a 10 out of
10 tour de force all those lost
subscribers they're about to come
crawling back now at this point we're
half an hour into the movie and like
this video nothing's really happened it
takes a while before anything actually
develops and i don't know if it was
intentional or not but this clearly
shows a struggle that massimo and laura
have when they're not banging or getting
drunk they don't really have anything in
common and you can see how she's torn
between him and having nacho and dip
can't show any of these scenes because
of youtube but use your imagination
that's really filthy that made to tone
that down i think that youtube is
actually so used to censoring this film
now that it doesn't even show the
thumbnails for this video which is why
most of them just look like stills from
the movie if you don't see this as the
thumbnail for the video then i'm right
and they've centered it now i've always
kind of thought that the series was
trying to show how vapid the lives that
the characters lead are might be giving
it too much credit but i think that it
shows a materialistic lifestyle filled
with nothing but sex and holidays
actually leads to people not ever being
happy look at me trying to psychoanalyze
this movie dear me anyway tone between
massimo and her feelings for nacho it
causes a lot of tension between the pair
laura also hid that they lost the baby
because of the gang war which makes
things kick off laura ends up traveling
out to portugal with olga who turns up
late because she couldn't leave her man
with a heart
such a good film anyway at this point
we're an hour in and things finally
start to happen when we discover that
nacho is out in portugal too that's
right we're one hour into the movie
probably would have just been 15 minutes
long if the director didn't keep filming
everything in slow motion but the island
is where things start to really get
going is it an island i don't moving on
unfortunately laura didn't order nachos
and after she bumps into his sister the
pair inevitably crossed paths after a
hilarious benny hill inspired chase
scene to get olga out the way the pair
finally hook up now unlike massimo nacho
will give her a choice in life and it
turns out that he saved massimo's life
by shooting anna last time now it's
revealed that he did this because he
actually wants laura to want him what's
this bloody 1970s feminism is it bloody
gone woke have you nacho are we not
kidnapping women for a year these days
bloody walk pc bullcrap i'm bloody sick
of it
now because he's entered massimo's
territory both through land and lakes
his crossing of the line has the
potential to cause a huge gang war
unfortunately after spending the night
with nacho she comes home to find
massimo there and in a complete opposite
of the conversation she's just had with
him massimo isn't too happy it's more
complicated than an entanglement and
laura threatens divorce after a trip
home her dad asks why she's been
starring in all these movies and she
also confesses that she's in love with
someone else after some incredibly wise
words from her mother we get a very
artistic threesome complete with a gay
kiss and it wasn't gay because it's in a
three-way it's not gay if it's in a
three-way with a honey in the middle
there's some leeway now after nacho
drops laura off in a taxi she ventures
out of the beach in order to see massimo
he pours his heart out to her and
reveals that he knows everything she's
being caught red-handed like changing
her tampon after a heavy flow and he
wanted to see if she would come back to
him here is the
sorry for that ladies no
really bad joke now here is the phrase
if you love something you should let it
go and the pair stand on the beach
staring at each other for about 10
minutes we as an audience are left
wondering whether the pair will end up
back together
and unfortunately we don't find out
there's no post-credits scene and as of
right in this video it has been said
that this will conclude the film series
the book also culminated with the third
entry and there is yet to be another one
announced now both the second and third
film was shot bare back to back which is
why they were able to be released right
next to the third book that also dropped
this year and believe it or not the
series has been a literary success with
the movies also constantly topping the
charts too i do believe that we will get
a fourth film now what this will center
around will likely be the gang war and
in order to make things even more tense
i think that laura is gonna have to
choose nacho over massimo now this will
likely infuriate the character as not
only did he steal his girl but he also
entered his territory which massimo
knows about though he seems cool calm
and calculated on this beach i think
this will likely be the last straw for
him and there's actually a lot teased at
in the final 15 minutes there's of
course a taxi ride in which nacho talks
about how it's war and the reveal that
massimo masa knows it all allura going
to nacho is the only way they can really
have a sequel because if she goes back
to massimo then it'll bury the hatchet
and be happily ever after nacho would
probably see this rejection too and stop
chasing her because he's bloody woke so
therefore the only way for them to
progress is for her to go to him she's
also saying stuff like i know you'd be a
good father one day which sounds like
the kind of thing someone says when
they're about to friendzone you
therefore this rejection could send
massimo over the edge and make it so
that he has to finally claim backwards
his the third book actually has laura
going off with nacho so maybe they're
kind of taking elements from that trying
to milk it as much as possible and then
we'll probably get a fourth movie next
year that's all shot in slow-mo two
hours long that's basically just the
last chapter of the source material now
that's how i think it's gonna go and
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it below very deep you've got an
opportunity here to write a 3 000 word
comment because it's a very very deep
and complicated subject as for my
thoughts
i think this is actually the worst out
of the three which is saying something
nothing really happens for the first 90
minutes and it doesn't even really have
an ending either so i'm not sure that
there was any point to it at all will i
be back for next time though you're god
damn right and because of that i'm
scoring it a generous two out of ten yes
that's right so i'll explain that so the
two is because my spotify is it it's now
going off and also the scenes were well
shot i think like like the camera was in
focus and stuff and it's difficult to
shoot in the dark but they still managed
to do it you know what i'm gonna bump it
up two or three cause right i can
imagine as well that these scenes the
sex scenes they're really awkward to
film but look they gave their all so so
that's it
no more after this
i'm not giving any more three out of ten
hope you enjoyed the video yeah and i'll
see you on the next one now if you if
you drop a comment here you're gonna get
entered into a competition where we're
giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on why
wouldn't you want to subscribe after
this and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the movie we pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners of the last one on
screen right now save that to you then
message me on twitter heavyspoilers you
want someone else with bloody walk
feminism in it then make sure you check
out our writing of she-hulk which will
be linked on screen right now the bloody
giving women choices these days what a
disgrace anyway that's linked on screen
and thanks for the support and i'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]